hangover there
[Music]
you're on you went on yeah I said no
that's guys Norris you can keep it on
you can keep it on it's on
I'm life see you cool so just go live uh
are we gonna do the receipts thing yeah
that'd be nice
so mom are you there's one little things
in the way of my screen I like seeing
myself on this Cruiser
oh that's the Chad that's cool all right
let me uh what I'm good I'm good okay
you move it you put it over to the right
there that's good it's real good
I'm not sure I like that actually cool
we're live amazing
Instagram what's up Facebook Twitter
YouTube super excited twitch big
shout-out to you
we YouTube is lit love it
first of all thank you so much to all of
you I've been busy all day
I just ran seven I'm gonna get so some
actually probably about my first sick
day I just ran seven avenues 7th avenues
not streets for you non-new Yorkers what
do you need what the logos not only the
logos yeah Nate's not ready by the way
so I'm here to like announce a very big
thing which is my wine project Nate and
John my partner's have failed
substantially because the websites not
ready to take orders because of a sales
tax issue they're feverishly working
they call me like seven minutes ago
literally as I have to I realize that I
have to jump out of the car and run
seven avenues a couple things if I was
fat Gary from four years ago I wouldn't
be here for another 20 minutes my cardio
is super up I'm excited about that we
have 6 a.m. basketball tomorrow
I'm ready number two I'm just really
pissed at me and trout they've been with
me for nine years they started as
interns and another wine projects they
were major players in vaynermedia Nate
was the best assistant I ever had
Oh Tyler
and uh and uh and and here we are in
this moment they finally become partners
in a business right Andy Andy can you
imagine when we finally do our business
together that you would drop the ball so
miserably that on the massive launch
that was been built up for a long time
how you feelin eight you're now eight
minutes behind work awesome
well anyway you know what we're here to
do a couple things first I'm gonna look
at all the comments what's up to
everybody so what the restream chat is a
consolidated chat
except for Facebook which is why I see
that so let me give some shoutouts Aaron
Taylor thank you so much for the happy
birthday the dope geek thank you so much
blaze camp racer extreme Marcel su
quando Glen Tierney cine evangelist I
love all of you guys thank you so much
we're here to do questions
so did we post anywhere well how we take
questions Andy is it up there we did not
post anywhere did you guys can you pin
it somewhere all right let's pin it
everywhere for everybody's watching
right now we're here to do a couple
things one make a massive announcement
of something I've been working on for
years yet the websites not ready but
we'll do that in a little bit number two
as you can see right down here I'm
trying to see it's cool you got it
really cool nice job oh this overlay
green thing is kind of rad as you could
see right now everybody's seeing it
except Instagram and sorry I'm not
seeing it so in three I'm you need to
listen let me give a big shout out to
some of the people on Instagram I'll
bear to a garden thank you so much you
could mere us thank you so much Dinah's
thank you so much thank you all so much
for being here on my birthday and I have
a present that I want which is yo you
like the Lord the bells amazing I have a
massive project that I've been working
on with my team that has failed me on
the website side that is a really
exciting thing that I'll tell you about
in a minute but number two I want to
answer your questions I want to do the
phone I want to be here for you and some
states screwed up
let's get questions and answers in so
down below you're seeing right now in a
screen or four Instagram that's
listening email me at Gary Vee team Gary
Vee team at vaynermedia calm in the
title put your question in the body put
your phone number
Gary Vee team for the next two hours I'm
going to answer a ton of questions
business
and wine and life I'm just looking at
Mike is really fun to watch the team
watching let's just show the team
watching like just think this super
matter not them the team might look
there they are they heard I hear they're
watching
so Gary Vee team at vaynermedia comm
asked a question in the title put your
phone number in the body and he's
looking at it we're about to take a
question and in a couple minutes I'm
gonna give the huge announcement that
I've been working on which is a
direct-to-consumer wine brand we're
cutting out the middle distributors and
retail stores
Sasha is gonna be super pissed with me
we're cutting out the middle we're
trying to produce the ultimate $20
bottle of wine and for my birthday it
would mean the absolute world for me if
you went on the website and bought as
soon as Nate's unbelievably worried face
Nate has aged dramatically in my face
you know in the last hour Nate has gone
from looking at like he was 31 Nate how
old are you exactly
great so he went from turning looking 31
- now he looks 36 quickly catching up to
44 year old John Troutman you have a
question not yet okay cool so let's talk
about things that are on my mind I just
got out of nonprofit what's that let me
talk to Instagram for a few minutes
well I'm here thank you guys so much
thank you for being here
Daily Bread out thank you so much Petra
thank you so much South thank assemblies
you have dialed is not unbelievable I
appreciate you're here uggs media what
up Natalie thank you so much for being
here dinero
what's up let me go over here Charles
Napa thank you so much James Perry the
third appreciate it - what's up my man
made a lot of people giving you love and
concerned voyage cap thank you so much
for 43 I appreciate that
there you Zachery thank you so much and
the chase good to see you I can't buy
wine I'm 18 that's that's absolutely
true please do not buy wine if you were
underage facebook without Brian Ramirez
good to see you Casey good to see you I
mean we're gonna start getting the
questions in a minute
please email me at Gary Vee team at vein
Mediacom put your question in the title
put your number you own number you're
working on your [ __ ] Oh for three
hard like these fun I'm gonna just start
answering questions for the screen
Connie big big shout out thank you so
much Leon Jacob thank you so much Barry
seal thank you so much for 33 the baller
crew the ball attract more baller cap B
ALR go check them out and for three City
the greatest soccer content site in the
world Taylor felt good to see you Thank
You Frankie man I'm super tight with my
Instagram community I just realize like
all these names coming through I'm like
oh I know what I mean like I know he
brought 13 alright who do we have here
well John it's Gary Vaynerchuk you're on
the Gary Vaynerchuk birthday bash with a
[ __ ] up website extravaganza how are
you I'm doing great
who's working the store over there I
already had like five or six phone calls
nobody and he was three I heard three
[ __ ] cause I get a challenge John
listen I wouldn't be [ __ ] complaining
and led to your glorious moment in life
hey I'm sorry okay
alright jump right in my question sure
will you be reviewing these wines
old-school Wine Library TV and it's not
wrong the camera back there and man
first of all thank you so much for
knowing a lot about me a lot of you are
watching right now
he didn't say mom my mother he said ma
Chris MOT big shadow to you cameraman
extraordinaire for three and a half
years of Wine Library TV s run I will
not be tasting these wines that
everybody is seeing right now on camera
because the wining side is dummy so the
packaging is dummy the wine that I'm
eventually gonna announce here to hook
all of you by though 20% of audience has
already left even though they were
willing to buy which Nate you've taken
enormous amounts of money out of our
pocket the wine comes out in February
June and October so the the wines kind
of sitting nicely in barrel we've got
some tasting coming up so I'm not gonna
taste it cuz it's not the actual wine
but when the wines are ready I will be
tasting but more importantly John here's
the really important question will you
be buying the wine shortly when I
actually allow you to
absolutely look you deliver so much
value any time any time you want to sell
something I'm buying for my brother
thank you for everything you do
I really appreciate brother let me tell
you a little bit about it so what I
really you know obviously we're looking
at all the trends I wanted to create a
product there's so much opportunity and
one of the things that we did here is we
leaned in heavily into the farmers so I
went we went to a bunch of landowners a
lot of farmers a lot of growers and
negotiated sick deals for red white and
Rose a then by cutting out the
distributor and the retailer basically
I'm desperately trying to create the
greatest $20 wine that tastes like a
forty to sixty dollar wine so I'm pretty
pumped about it man and then the big
kicker which I'm about to explain to
everybody in a minute is if you join
claw the club because I'm gonna unveil
the name in a minute it's right behind
me people already know but nonetheless
it's more fun to make Nate stress cuz he
was gone from 36 to 42 now in the last
minute the there's a club that if you
buy a case of each each year if you get
a case in each you know of the Rose a
white and red if you could sign up for
that club we've created an SMS service
that allows you to ask your wine
questions or your wine needs at all
times so if you had if you were going to
Napa and wanted a VIP tour you literally
text a phone number and we set you up or
if you needed to buy a bottle of wine
for a boss you text and we reply or if
you were going out to dinner and like
took a picture of the menu or sent us a
link to the restaurant you're going to
we would tell you which wine Sauder
literally Osama yeah in your pocket wow
that's unbelievable
yeah I'm pretty so the wine the wine
when you buy a case of each gets down to
20 bucks a bottle so for me for seven
hundred twenty bucks for a lot of people
the service is worth it let alone the
three cases of wine to twenty bucks so
I'm super excited about it we're about
tyleshia in a minute so you but you
don't know when you don't know one that
you don't know it's good we get it I
mean you don't know yet it oh we were
supposed to get at 16 minutes ago but me
and John Troutman actually cuz Nate's
actually been working it's more Trouty
they've been
all I know is New York City can now buy
some about to probably announce just on
that I'm trying to debate in my mind
right now I'm trying to I'm trying to
debate right now if if I should like to
let everybody by and then we adjust
sales tax after the fact so I'm gonna
let meat and trout sweat for another ten
minutes but I don't want to lose
everybody and like and not get to the
punchline of it so we'll see all right
well I appreciate you taking my call I
put me down for whatever a case and I'll
just look for whenever I could buy and
that's happening right now keep doing
the great though thank you buddy so what
you guys think to New York and by all
right so let's do this there's a bunch
of people on stream I can open it up
completely right now but what will
happen is some of you won't be charged
sales tax and will you'll probably see
another charge either later less sales
tax there might be some more right right
because there's some city versions of
the sales tax right so what in all the
streams Facebook Instagram and all the
collective's twitch YouTube Twitter do
you think I should open it up right now
and let you all by and then if you get
another charge for like 15 bucks or nine
bucks or eight bucks like an hour later
then or tomorrow morning is that a good
idea should I open it up yes or should I
wait no yes or no
Instagram yes no by the way big shout
out Massachusetts Texas Illinois I can
now ship to you with this project so I'm
super excited bout it so what do you
guys think should I open it up yes or no
leave in the comments should I open it
up yes or no
I appreciate 1k business thank you
should I go yes or no that's what I'm
looking for a yes or no a yes or a No
open open just got in but yes I really
I'm gonna redirect email soon happy
birthday you got a question
it looks like give me quite good
questions people are saying yes open it
up [ __ ] it I'm gonna do it like like
right all right so one more question why
you guys feel like it's close so what a
lot of manual work for you guys why is
it a mess the site's not working but you
don't give a [ __ ] about bad customer
experience you mean bad customer
experience that they get charged $729
and then a day later at 8 bucks right
it's 240 240 240 hey Gary Vaynerchuk
Tammy its Gary Vaynerchuk but you know
that how are you happy birthday how are
you I'm amazing kinda ish Tammy when's
your birthday January is it January 20th
23rd oh close ajaces to 28 how are you
I'm great I'm great I just happened to
catch on I love it when I see you live
I love being live I really wish I could
be selling a shitload of wine I'm thirty
[ __ ] thousand cases to sell and and
[ __ ] nature run over here [ __ ]
telling me three more minutes so I'm
gonna take his word for it I'm gonna
wait five more minutes and if it's not
ready I'm gonna punch Trouty in the face
and I'm gonna leave and just say you
know what you guys figure out itself
thirty thousand cases because I'm not
your monkey anymore and going live to
try to sell some wine fair enough oh
these guys will be on the street selling
at guarantee just for you please Jon
Sammy you should just meet their day
what question do you have what can I
answer for you so my question I am
actually hosting my very first
Thanksgiving we have about over 30
people
everyone should be arriving probably
about 1 o'clock dinner at 3 what would
be a great wine this is amazing
Nora why don't you jump it get over here
we have to introduce you to the world so
we made a substantial hired notice I've
been yelling at Nate and Trouty why
don't you say hello to everybody and
tell everybody your background because
I'm gonna let her I'm we're both gonna
answer but you're an enormous part of
our team you're you're the brains of the
organization clearly these I mean forget
I'm just I'm just like look the
character what you know tell everybody
who you are and what and what your
background is don't be don't be my name
is Nora I'm working with charity and
Nate so my background I actually am I've
been working in New York City for five
years
three is a sommelier in restaurants so
I'm here to help all of you pick your
wines and just have a really great
customer experience and Nora is much
more than that obviously we're gonna
lean into her brains Trouty even though
I'm mad at him right now knows a
fuckload about wine Nate and I are
dangerous but Nora what so thirty people
coming over first Thanksgiving she wants
to make everybody super pumped what kind
of wine what where do you start with the
Thanksgiving wine style wine it's
actually good to do large-format and for
Thanksgiving I think in my family at
least we like to do more like medium
bodied red wine I think you can get
really great value from Beaujolais who
knows really for everybody watching cuz
I don't I get too nerdy the Beaujolais
Nouveau that has all the flowers on it
not so much Cru Beaujolais is the stuff
you find like fifteen to twenty dollars
a bottle that is incredible wine that I
think all US nerds agree is grossly
underpriced and a great substitute for
like $40 Pinot Noir okay my background
actually I spent the majority of my time
at an Italian restaurant
I really think you can't go wrong with
Italian wine and Barbera dhaba is a
really great varietal and a mixture of
stark and read through it
more immediate and body I think really
friendly for a crowd and then I think
you can get some really great value and
Sangiovese a territory as well that's
kind of one of great for Thanksgiving
there's lots of savory elements to it
and also some really great red fruit
that I think goes with Turkey and any
side that you can really have without a
sauce thank you
so the other thing I'm gonna make this a
little bit easier for some people cuz
you're a super [ __ ] wine smart one
thing that I like a verse for meaner and
Rieslings one thing that I think is
really what's that mean you think we're
good
me I know you will you'll do that anyway
like you're a great guy like that what
you're feeling decent okay so I'm gonna
figure I'm gonna finish this question
for Tam and then we're gonna open up
announce the name of the winery and
really lean into the whole story Tam New
Zealand Sauvignon Blanc I'm getting very
hot on this turkey is dry stuffing is
dry like there's a lot of dryness so
fruit and acidity is a really good play
i weirdly think that New Zealand
Sauvignon Blanc is really great because
when your friends first come over they
just want a wine that's light and easy
and you can just drink it without any
food or if you're passing around cheese
and other [ __ ] like that you can just
use that as well and he's doing
something walk is super easy to find as
well so I'm huge on that perfect awesome
guys speaking of a rose day or even
doing a sangria and mixing some of the
right blends like a Syrah or something
with and some fries what I don't know if
I should go that way no no on that note
like I just like to wear your energies
at which is this is the biggest truth
which is like drink what the [ __ ] you
want just keep in mind that Thanksgiving
is dry I keep that in mind which is why
I like sangria even with a little sugar
cuz there's a dry call like people give
me like my turkeys juicier it's fine
it's not that [ __ ] juicing like
turkey is dry stuffing is dry so just
keep that in mind which is why fruit and
sugar at some level is your friend
Timlin for calling of course I think I'm
in California too far from that
right now we have a little bit of smoke
sup haze and there yeah we are I'm sorry
about a good two hours away I'm in the
Central Valley by the hour from Stanford
ya know what Mae area coming are the lab
for Tim but here's the most important
question in 87 seconds when I unveil
this URL and the ability to buy will you
be buying some wine thank you
alright let's do it [ __ ] it here we go
my friends everybody's watching
Instagram here we go twitch YouTube
Twitter Instagram Facebook I am
announcing right now the creation of
what probably is my lifelong journey as
a little boy in a liquor store to this
moment
I always thought and dreamed that one
day I would have my own winery yet it
felt like I was 87 years old and super
Yoda looking right and had like some
weird dog even though I'm not the
biggest dog lover I know that's gonna
cause a lot of comments but you know I
like humans but I always thought it'd be
like super shadowed out little did I
know that the internet would continue to
consume my life and I am now in a place
where a direct-to-consumer brand in the
same way that you know Birchbox or Lola
or Harry's or Warby Parker or all these
incredible things my ambition with my
partners who I'm starting to feel better
about Nate and John and our incredible
brains of the organization Nora
our ambition is to create the greatest
direct-to-consumer wine brand in the
world to create the greatest $20 bottle
of wine which I believe is the magic
price point of wine because so many of
you drink wine at 12 to 15 dollars
and don't realize what happens when you
go to 20 in quality I'd rather you drink
eight then drink 13 because 13 so much
closer to 20 which feels more like 30
and 40 when you know how to buy we went
out and looked at a lot of vineyards a
lot of farmers a lot of partners been
the bottle big shout out everybody else
how are we gonna do this what are we
gonna do how are we gonna make this
ultimate $20 bottle of wine well it
starts with getting the best grapes
having the most empathy for the farmers
having them part of the equation and
then eliminating the middle the
distributors and the wine retail stores
my pop store us that middle and going
directly from the farmer to you sit in
the middle negotiate strong over here my
big plan was make the farmers famous
what you'll be seeing from us when's our
film coming out do we have a film or is
that the film on the website the full
documentary is gonna be next September
oh I love that cool anyway we're gonna
miss huge documentary from day one
meetings a bus formulating it's super
cool stuff we're gonna make the we're
gonna make the farmers who help us make
this wine famous so that they can sell
their grapes for more money so you go
out and find their wines when they're
not in this wine and we're going to have
the most respect for you and so here we
are I'm unbelievably proud to present
empathy winery whoever has the most
empathy for the two parties I believe
makes the greatest wine in the world
I'm so honored we are making a rose a
which will be coming out in February
we're making a white which is coming out
in May June we're making a red that's
coming out in October and I'm
unbelievably proud of it I'm ready to
answer questions about it but most of
all please go to empathy wines calm
right now I want to ring bells and
here's what I'm setting up if you join
Club empathy which is a case of each
seven hundred twenty dollars a year you
can fail to forty at a time when they
come out you'll get well to forty right
now for the Rose a which comes in
February and then in May June when the
white comes you'll get billed to forty
and October when the red comes out
you'll get billed to forty twenty bucks
a bottle
seven hundred twenty bucks a year three
cases of wine you don't have to think
anymore the best Rose a white and red
coming to your doorstep Chicago Illinois
Dallas Texas Boston Massachusetts three
places that I've wanted to send wine to
for the last decade and I couldn't
because of the retail loss the winery
laws allowed me to empathy wines calm
there it is right down there please go
there right now but if you sign up for
the club empathy a case of each you get
a sommelier in your pocket you get an
SMS number that allows you to text and
we help you with all your wine needs
corporate gift ideas will reply going to
Napa on your
honeymoon will reply going to Italy for
a week in the summer will reply need a
wine for your boss will reply need
whatever you want going to this big
fancy restaurant and scared to order the
line will reply our team me sometimes
nor a quite a bit
trout quite a bit will keep building our
team we've got an office in London
vaynermedia has got an office in
Singapore coming in to get a question
here going we're gonna create this
ecosystem we're gonna cry literally
think for 720 bucks if you're really a
wine drinker the service is more
valuable than no goddamn wine you get
the three case of wine but we also have
three six and twelve right three six
twelve we have three and six bottle
packages you can buy three bottles of
each a year you can buy six bottles of
each you'll see on the website that
they're a little more than twenty bucks
a bottle when you go that route but I'm
unbelievably unbelievably excited about
this Brad thank you much for say I'm
gonna go in the comments here guys if
you want to buy me a birthday present if
I brought you any value in your life
what's the lowest cost thing eighty the
eighty one bucks times three right
so it's eighty one bucks times to Ray
right so two hundred forty bucks if I
brought you any value what is going on
here we've got a little birthday cake
here look at this this is nice work a
little empathy birthday cake I know you
want that Emily honey I know you want to
eat that cork I get it super nice look
this is this is a big moment for me and
more portly a lot of business people
watching right now I know how you guys
roll like I know exactly how you guys
roll Instagram like if you want to ask
questions about the model if you want to
do certain things I'm super duper duper
duper excited about this Oh stuffs
coming in when we get would he gotten
better what's going on what's that give
me updates what's going on to site the
site is overwhelmed okay understood now
I see some Europe questions
great news Germany Europe UK the answer
is yes we're working on this we're
hoping for early summer to be able to
ship internationally
okay if you refresh if you're having a
card issue it will be good whoo hey
what's up Andre dude first and foremost
before your question are you buying any
of this wine
all right yuge I'll probably back home
to my white oh yeah Andre don't [ __ ]
with me I don't want the probably for my
wife I'm like I need you in man I need
you in for at least the three bottle
pack you need to get three nice bottles
of Rose a in February three nice bottles
of white in June and three nice bottles
of red bro or I'll [ __ ] die right now
are you in or you out I'm gonna have to
do it crazy over here I'll be by for my
way further Christmas I be free off
I appreciate it brother what uh what can
I answer for you well they're originally
my question what's your favorite at a
childhood memory of a birthday whether
your birthday or a friend's birthday
will you remember what did you doing my
sister my sister my sister called me
today and said opening line
I can't believe on your 10th birthday
you bought me a Cabbage Patch with your
birthday money you've been nicer from
the beginning my favorite memory is that
when I realized I was a very kind soul
was when I bought what my grandmother
took me to Toys R Us in Woodbridge New
Jersey I had all my money that I got we
went there it's prime 1985 Cabbage Patch
Kids craze we walk in I'm super [ __ ]
focused on wrestling figures from LJN
right i SuperDuper gimme i SuperDuper
want like this right this is what I'm
looking for
we get there I get caught by the end cap
of GI Joes which excites me a little bit
and then I hear my sister screaming they
have Cabbage Patch Kids she doesn't have
one and I took all my money and bought
her a Cabbage Patch man that I believe
that's why everybody who's watching
should buy three cases of empathy wife
no honestly brother thank you so much
for watching any of my content I hope
it's brought you value and honestly if
you go now right now and dude by the
three-pack case that means a lot to me
yeah you grab me
man I really appreciate you I want to
give a quick shout out to Val moaning
now Mona we got Gary Gunther and Bill
common today is actually one of my good
buddies
birthdays he passed away it was
carefully went down he was in the Navy
because of the West Virginia and sorry
to hear that brother dick to man so I
really appreciate you answering my phone
call me I really appreciate I appreciate
you man I'm sorry for that loss and I'm
really glad we got to talk brother I
really do know I really appreciated I
knew the back thank you for the
appreciative go happy birthday thank you
brother
Margit Rose I can see the twitch at I
can see the twitch chat I can see the
YouTube chat I see the Twitter chat
I see Jarrod Osbourne I see Patrick Big
Kahuna Big Kahuna Patrick's in the
building I love it he's here
Jeff tank Gold dreams on Instagram thank
you guys so much Kahuna I'll [ __ ] beat
your big face in if you don't buy Club
empathy bro I'm telling you this isn't
this is this this is not veiny a cab I
need you buy all three rows a white
Cunha I don't want to [ __ ] hear it
kun if you buy a [ __ ] Club empathy a
case of each send me the receipt and I a
hundred percent one if I can sit down
and kiss your [ __ ] fat face
I miss you Kahuna the number by the way
real quick here's the biggest part I
haven't announced this yet if you buy
Club empathy if you go to the site right
now and buy a case of each and by the
way if you buy three cases of [ __ ]
whining year you should be buying Club
empathy if you like three cases of wine
a year if that's what you do if you look
36 bottles going through your [ __ ]
home ever in a year I want you to buy
Club empathy right now because a will be
on your beggin call and sms be it would
just mean the world to me if you
supported this lifelong mission see it's
gonna be better than the wine you buy
like I don't understand like it's better
you're buying it right are you 21 okay
guys thank God so anyway here's the big
punch line I'm gonna do a contest
anybody who buys a receipt where am i
sending the receipt to me where are we
printing the receipts for them who's
this
Nevin it's gary waiter Nevin it's Gary
[ __ ] Vaynerchuk holy [ __ ] i hi hi
thanks for calling me I appreciate that
my pleasure bro what's up I was learning
to do this live audit my social people I
got good news
are you buying any empathy wine I don't
actually drink I apologize
how old are you I am 26 do you know any
human beings that drink I do do you do
you think you can give 9 bottles away in
a year yeah I actually found my first
sponsorship for my podcast down I'll use
that money I'll buy you not bottles if
you ship to Canada okay
Canada's [ __ ] Nate we're working on
it brother you know I'm gonna audit your
social where's my [ __ ] phone what's
your social in Evan Webster and Evi and
WPBF ter all right I'm looking at your
Instagram first of all the child is
gorgeous thank you number two your
current picture of you laughing doing
your podcast is amazing thank you you're
welcome
number three I really appreciate that
that's fine but here comes the other
stuff number are you replying to the
comments I think we absolutely I'm happy
about that as well how often are you
you're not posting enough you're being
too close I'm posting every single day
and then I'm in a small town now people
were saying I'm spamming them tell them
to go [ __ ] themselves I think you need
to I think you need to tell them that
because you're not posting too much post
more often I like where you're going
with Instagram ah I would I like that
you got the tool thing the podcast where
you've got this where you've got the
emoji of the tool and the idea I would
use literal words people they're
confused sometimes so I would do that I
like we did with highlights I like that
you're doing stories I'd like you to
post more often how many Instagram
stories are you doing a day I used to be
doing like 10 but I turned it down
yeah behavior so kind of quick people in
my podcast no no no the way you push
people to the podcast is guilt do you
know why I'm about to sell 10,000 K
of wine right now because everybody
who's watching realizes I've actually
brought them value in their lives and if
they drink wine or if they're like you
and they don't drink wine but there's a
way to give away nine bottles a year
they're gonna sign up for the club right
like like really like with all the free
content I've given you around the last
six years
really you're gonna go to Albertsons or
BevMo or Total Wine and just pick up
some random bottles instead of signing
up for this are you out of your [ __ ]
mind
no okay totally get it yeah yeah yeah so
like I always put out such great content
that people feel the same way and buy
from you as well I'm gonna keep cracking
it thank you throw jabs brother not
right hooks Canada will be this summer
I'm gonna literally find you never to
make sure you sign up when you can take
your money from Canada Congrats brother
keep doing it alright what's the update
the site's slow not slow we're good how
we do what sales good coming in all good
stuff okay good
let me make the full announcement and II
don't make any calls if you're watching
right now sign up for club empathy which
is when you order a case of each right
and and what I'm going to do is print
print your receipts where are we sending
the receipts where are we sending the
receipts or are we printing them on the
back and we're putting on a bad again
okay here's the big announcement if you
buy a case of each and join club empathy
I am right now gonna print out your name
on a paper and at 7:30 exactly in an
hour and 20 minutes I'm gonna pull out
of a bag or a box or whatever they put
it in and one of you who buys Club
Anthony I'm gonna fly to New York City
and have dinner left we have a bunch of
wine and have dinner eighty thousand
dollar value according according to free
based on auctions that people pay to
have dinner with me so I've seen the
sushi I'm gonna have one piece cuz I
think I'll see anyway Instagram I expect
all 1200 of you right now to go to
empathy wines calm empathy wines calm
can we pin empathy wines , my it's
around
mm-hmm hello Instagram I'm busy watch
calm all right what's going on in
facebook
we got tray tray camera Jorge Rios what
up from Mexico not able to put age in
the order brother Johnny marcinho trying
to figure that out
ordering the wine love this Thank You
Jana Kaitlyn Johnson thank you so much
Jonathan Rebecca
Jonathan Rebecca James says it's not
working we need somebody cm in facebook
Nora or whatever you need to pick some
buddies got to see him the Facebook
trying to enter your site but can't get
past the birthday pop-up
cláudio cool oh nice guys anybody who's
having a problem on with empathy whines
calm there's a little pop up on the
right hand side both on the mobile and
only on desktop so what do the mobile
[ __ ] do is the empathy empathy whines
all right and keep and keep up keep up
you don't call in if you nuke them if
you want your question on you're holding
it too hard too hard can you not know
boom look at that sorry Andy magic touch
those are winners by somebody but you
call them for these whoo oh I want to
say thank you did Patrick do that
Patrick [ __ ] you bro I love you so much
is that true Patrick P nobody else is
gonna be Kuna yeah Kahoot is 35 and
aol.com dude I [ __ ] look guys is he
Kahuna I love your face so much dude if
you actually bought two Club empathise
right now I'm coming to your house in
Jersey and we're gonna hang out I miss
you guys miss all the old forum beeps uh
okay so here's the punch line let me let
me recap for everybody jumping in right
now just joining us instagram what's up
look empathy whines calm empathy whines
calm please go check it out right now
trying to make the ultimate $20 bottle
of wine not super complicated I want to
make the best $20 bottle of wine of all
time
how do we do that that's why we named it
empathy whoever has the most empathy for
the grower whoever has the most empathy
for the consumer produces the best wine
in the world right and so it's a little
bit so how do I do that I make the
wineries famous for them to give me a
better price on the grapes we cut out
the distributor and the retailer my
former life which allows us to actually
deliver this kind of wine for 20 bucks
Club empathy is our kicker
it's our sommelier in SMS if you buy a
case of each which drives it all the way
down to 20 bucks a bottle
you get billed right now for the rose a
which comes in February but in June and
October all in the red and white come
out you get billed then so good for you
on cashflow Sam but Ruby you're fine
there boom
now you're immediately in Club empathy
you're going to Paris you need help
pickup my boom what's that
Nora no come over here John show your
face and tell us the story so we had an
early friends and family member that
bought through the site
they were planning their honeymoon we
set them up in Napa nor actually
deserves all the credit here we set them
up Brad for different appointments yep
all comped yep all amazing tasters set
them up with dinner reservations we
lined up their entire itinerary form and
they say they saved that alone they
saved the two of them tasting for free
at high-end wineries like listen here's
the real arbitrage if you actually go to
Napa Valley once a year
or like a play it on you should buy Club
empathy you're basically getting 36
bottles of wine for free because
everything we do by being your wine
servants it's like arbitrage is out so
we need a ton of deals with wineries so
that we don't charge you when you go
actually having somebody set up your
restaurant things picking you up by the
way you know how many of you need
holiday gifts is there a corporate
there's a cork we're doing this right
there's another thing this actually is
what I should have started with consider
this is a business organization right if
you're on if you're buying corporate
gifts put corporate gifts and a phone
number right now Andy find somebody I
want to do a corporate gift stay alive
this is some QVC Network [ __ ] I want to
if you're look a lot of you right now
we're just starting to think of
your corporate gift if your baller
customers worth seven hundred twenty
bucks allow us to do this with you you
buy Club empathy we send you a gorgeous
invitation did you figure that out with
bond it's already doing or what yet
working on it it's ok Andy is my
corporate client you got seven to twenty
to thirty ballers some of your big
companies Wall Street people thinks that
nature maybe you have a hundred of them
you want a real corporate gift instead
of some [ __ ] [ __ ] gift
certificate or something that nature
cliche boom you buy club epithelia SMS
service for wine for the full year boom
they get wine three times so you bought
a corporate gift they get a beautiful
wedding like invitation for the holidays
right now
that you got it for them that we work on
hand and hand for you then in February
they get a case of wine then in June
they get a case of wine then in October
to get a case of wine and it's all love
for you guys
Cody don't late honor nobility Oh
anytime you got my gift here I'm hearing
a lot of don't do this rub thanks both
I'm don't distract me I'm selling here
I'm teaching I'm educating you got a
corporate gift yet what are you
searching Facebook Twitter no yeah I
need you to find one out of the comments
if you're looking for corporate can't do
Australia yet sorry jack
US corporate only Illinois Massachusetts
Texas I've not been able to do wine
business with you ever this is finally
our chance I'm very excited so if you
live in all these free states you
haven't been able to buy from Wine
Library ever we have our chance you got
one in what is the corporate URL empathy
wine calm slash Jesus Christ great can
somebody create garyvee calm slash gift
you're doing it Gary be calm slash gift
that's it that will be working shortly
don't put that in here Gary Vee calm
sashka Jake yeah what's up brother
Hogan chef good where do you live
I'm in Reno Nevada third I love a
brother so I hope Andy picked you
properly are you in the market for
corporate gifts yes started sending out
my gift yet to my my clients and I'm
looking for something that I can kick
out then I can tell the story behind
this person is finding you value i I
bought their there their wine club and
what I can do is ask you know what's
your favorite wine or you a robe a guy
white guy your red guy and then I'll
have all three so love it so couple
things if you sign up for empathy wines
the way we sell it is in packs right so
right three packs is the entry which
gets you three rows a three white three
red in three times a year right and you
can charge based on when you're going to
receive them correct correct you get
charged up front for the rose a so if
you decide to buy packages now you would
get charged for the Rose a and then
you'd get charged in June for the white
and October May June for the white and
October for the red you get it depends
on how much if you go to the website
it's super simple and broken down there
what are the three numbers it's 20
what is it 20 what so here's how we did
it if you buy three bottles
it's $27 if you buy six bottles it's 24
in 25 25 when you buy the cases it's 20
bucks a bottle
twelve so like for example let's work
backwards
how many key clients do you have I've
been at looking for my pop point wait
what do you want - what are you thinking
you're gonna spend on the top 20 per
person if I could spend 20 bucks on each
person's top 20 that's all I say so
here's gonna be your problem the moat
the minimum you can do for somebody is
what is 240 right because it's for
forget what I'd love to do is if I could
have these corporate gifts sent to me
then I can put my own personal you can't
cut you got them you can and I can I
could join the club that's exactly right
brother Hackett I [ __ ] love when
people back
sounds awesome to me because then like
you said I can see my cash flow going
I can yep the first is I see fit I'll
and I'll have a little bit of value
behind my actual get respect dude thank
you so much for uh can I give it yeah
give a shout-out to a winery that you
may not have heard of it's sort of a new
guy I know too personally please it's
called Basin and Range winery and this
guy's in Minden Nevada
he's right in between the Sierra Nevadas
and the bacon ring he's the highest
elevation vineyard in the United States
you've got a specific type of shale rock
that he's using and it's supposed to be
a great wine I haven't gotten a chance
to take that myself yet but the guy's a
great dude I'd love to give them a shout
out
Ethan and range yo Justin wait a hack
brother I love it thank you all right
close to 50 people are already in the
club that means 50 people bought a case
of each yes okay so only 10,000 more of
them awesome alright so we need 10,000
more we got 50 so far I need 10,000 more
of you watching to do that let me one
more time
d-roc tell me when the Gary Vee calm
slash gift works we're live put it up
here guys I don't got the green screen
Gary good job I look at the team working
this is very exciting
all right couple things I think a lot of
you should buy this for your corporate
gift it's seven hundred twenty bucks a
person so I need some real high-end
people that are 17 years into their
finite sandman Ruby when you were
dominating the radio industry back in
the 20s and 30s right what like Howie
big clients that you have or when you
were where were you yeah you would have
clients for now would you buy yeah how
much how much would you spend on a gift
like 154 Dom P got a great arrange so
I'm trying to think how I want to do
this there's a 724 the club 243 is the
entry level to be part of this project
right cuz you're going to charge 81 3
you know three times a year I want to do
something crazy for some people's
businesses I'm gonna do this so real
quick what I'm about to do I'm just
gonna talk it through what I want to say
is if I know there's some big ballers
out
that have 50 VIP clients and I was about
to say if you're one of the first five
people to buy the 50 packs right for 50
of your corporate gifts I will on top of
the fact that this is a good gift and I
think really worth it will blow people
away and if your salesmen like me the
fact that a case is coming every 3-4
months wins because that's how it's
really done right you give one gift like
like anytime right now has something in
a box he's giving me a gift set my dear
friend a time it looks amazing today
right he has a great like grain
restaurant tour right hunt fish club the
reason you see so much of my content
there the man the proprietor he has
something in a box
he's been hyping this gift today's my
birthday I don't know if you know he's
been hyping this gift so he's about to
give me a bit gift I'm gonna be blown
away cuz he knows me we like the same
stuff wrestling this and that whatever
it is right but then that's it I have a
high for like a day or a week but then
in four months it kind of goes away
right what's great about this am BK is
the client gets this in February oh yeah
I like Sam benroubi
in June all right I like Sam the Ruby
and oh [ __ ] right now I have a big deal
to do maybe I'll call Sam the Ruby and
October and so that's why I think it's a
perfect corporate gift because you're
reinforcing the relationship for 7:20
what I was gonna say Nate is the first
five people that buy 50 for their
clients right now I will make a personal
video for their company in them to the
people that they send it to so we can
send an email and say you know hey it's
Gary Vaynerchuk Rick you know bought
this for you let me tell you a little
better this maybe I can I print like so
what would happen like so okay you're on
the other side right now you're like
holy [ __ ] that's a good idea
I'm gonna buy 50 of these right now cuz
the video with Gary's work that I can
really important that I have an agency
they said how would they buy that right
now just when they when I have to put in
50 different places they do want to
don't they do they don't want to look at
50 individual times
let's do this but there's a little thing
on the desktop are you me at empathy
whines calm all right here's what we're
doing like just talk it was somet up new
thing if you're one of the first five
people to buy 50 cases for your 50 top
clients a 50 packs yes sir no no they're
buying for 50 clients no not 50 cases 50
clients 150 cases 30 clients 727 20
right yeah 150 cases there it's like me
right like we have 50 big time clients
but I'll be more than happy to spend 724
if you're one of the first five people
who either and this is how you clean it
you hit the little chat on the bottom of
your of empathy whines calm and say I'm
in put your name and literally noir or
John are literally gonna call you right
now and lock it in or you email Nate at
empathy whines calm and say you're I'm
in actually John are you gon okay you
don't charge of this John you haven't
done anything yet so this is good good
to put you in charge of something which
is good because that means that you
didn't break the website that was not
Nate on a serious note though John John
at Jo Ann guys there is no empathy
whines without John's ramen as much as I
love to razz and things that nature his
energy and his partnership with me over
the last decade and more important his
interest in this industry including when
he went to work for incredible
distributor to being select and his
energy like absolutely foundational to
this partnership he's gonna take the
first five requests either you hit the
chat below on a desktop and say hey John
to me is that overwhelmed right now
so all to John have empathy wine-soaked
I'm done the first five people to email
john jo n at empathy whines comm that
says they're in for the 50 packages for
their clients put in your phone number
John Flory gonna leap and call you and
lock you in first five people I will
make a custom video for as well but by
the way firm buddies watching if you
have one client that you give a [ __ ]
about you should buy this now I'm
talking business this is kind of why we
structured it this way in my opinion the
reason I was so confident that this
project is this is literally
I've been in the best corporate gift
strategy a reoccurring gift that plays
out throughout the year wine always
kills you get a rose a in february/march
by the way let me tell you what's gonna
happen I'm gonna save you a preview you
see this you see this like holding it
like this whole from February Jean next
year on Instagram you were gonna see
every famous and cool person take a
photo with this bottled wine so now
you're sending it to a CMO a banker and
now they see a wrestler a four-person
million person influencer unattractive
dude with ABS a pretty girl an actor a
comedian a mean maker a rapper a social
influencer holding this up and you're
the one that sent it to him first
this brand I'm just gonna save you a lot
of time whether it's supreme or a kid or
adidas or sprayground backpacks this
wine brand will be the number one
coolest wine brand in the world in the
next nine months right because when Bo
takes a nice little selfie of him
drinking it at hunting fish then Bo's
audience is gonna give a [ __ ] wait you
see many basketball players are drinking
up if he wants I'm gonna have the whole
[ __ ] MBA drinking this [ __ ] what's
happening me good I like a dish
do you understand Instagram where this
is going all right want to ring some
bells if you bought more than one Club
empathy if you've bought two club map of
these for yourself because some people
buying six cases for yourselves put your
phone number in right now I want Andy to
call and I want to thank you now 50
people so far I bought the club empathy
right I'm about to print out all the
receipts if you are in for the case of
each for the year I'm gonna print out
every receipt and at the end in about an
hour I'm going to pull one of your names
out I'm gonna fly you in we're gonna
have dinner in New York City that's the
contest this is the time to buy tomorrow
you're gonna buy it not as good a time
right now one person during this live
stream another thing to remind you it is
my birthday I don't want a gift I don't
anything I want you by empathy whines I
don't don't send me a Charles Barkley
rookie card
don't send me
anything I don't anything I don't want
jets anything it would mean the world to
me if you at least minimally bought a
3-pack recurring of rows a white and red
everything why is the best $40 wine for
20 bucks that's my dream
alright let's get some phone calls going
enough enough information time to engage
let me engage you here
Chad good to see you Emily thank you so
much Miguel Isabel Mariana I don't know
what's going on back said Andres what's
up everybody who's International this is
going to be available in the summer
here's the big thing by the way if
you're in on Facebook I'm gonna do this
right now I just want to say thank you a
ton if you're in on Facebook say say I'm
in and and tell me what you bought I
just want to thank you if you're in on
Facebook right now I just want to rattle
off thank yous if say you're in and say
you're in for a three pack of six pack
or a 12 pack like how'd you do it did
you buy the recurring three pack did you
buy the reoccurring six pack or did you
buy the reoccurring Club empathy that
gives you the SMS activity you're trying
to figure out some stuff Andy I want
some interaction here I just want to say
if I've ever brought you any value and
you want to give me a birthday present
this would mean the world to me even a
three-pack go buy something oh by the
way for everybody who wants to support
the camp by wine just sharing this on
social empathy wines calm empathy wines
calm oh it's on you're buying [ __ ]
love you man
Christine bow let's go Bo D millennial
travel around the world what up Natalie
what's up happy birthday Ashley thank
you so much this has got a super lag
right like what kind of like feels even
more than that it's more net you're
looking at it real time are people
saying they're in first about
all right amazing thank you so much all
right we need phone numbers phone
numbers in facebook on YouTube I'm in
for friend or in 2121
yes excuse me I don't believe you but I
promise you I'll call that person right
now call let's call what's the phone
number okay you know that you know that
you're getting trolled right you guys
are feeling real listen I thought by the
way when we made this I was most worried
about a thousand or two thousand case by
like throwing up our skews but like I'm
[ __ ] here to sell let's go I'm in for
club empathy thank you so much Courtney
Rowe
please print my receipt out I got six
bottles home and thank you so much Sam
Parker Canada shipping is coming
somewhere in in kind of like the summer
June July mates I'm in for order 101
12-pack baby Thank You Chad Davis
thought the record Ryan Davis thank you
what
so let's can I call okay no problem I'm
super fun thank you so much Vincenzo's
Lindy no that's my guy Jeff Shapiro
thank you so much club empathy
dude I'm trying to explain to people how
big of a deal Club Peppa Thea's if
you're a wine drinker if you go to Napa
once a year or if you're planning going
to cheer or if you have a honeymoon or
vacation or a wedding anniversary you
should buy it just to guest set up your
Napa trip
yes Nate I know you're probably getting
married any day what's up
that's some good content right there
what do you got no races thank you so
much everybody the Big W that's old
school right there how much is a three
pack driving so can't get their website
Courtney a three pack is 83 dollars 8081
dollars hello it's Gary Vaynerchuk
who's this Jeff it's a real pleasure man
thank you for being on I'm happy
birthday uh thank you so much bro what's
going on where you from I'm from
Milwaukee I love it are you Brewers fan
are you Packer fan yes I am you know
that we have Josh Jackson and Geronimo
Allison from Vayner sports repping you
guys what's going on man what can you if
you want to answer something I'm happy
to answer huh did you buy any clothes
did you buy any empathy whines I didn't
but I shared I shared almost hung up on
him but he was fast
he was fast with the sheriff's all
answer you should spend your marketing
on Instagram story ads it's the biggest
or Instagram story ads right now is the
best by marketing thank you thank you
bro so much where could I drink empathy
in Portugal Jose not yet not yet lose
some pickles
not yet but oh thank you Mark mark a
moon in for the three-pack thank you so
much thank you so much
International shipping coming this
summer the rose' will be in the market
already the white will be closed I'll be
really interesting to see Vincenzo's in
for [ __ ] Club empathy that means a
ton to me signed up for club empathy
booed coming to 4ds in January Jason
keen Thank You Kristen magar thank you
for ordering three thank you so much hey
it's Gary Vaynerchuk oh my god this is
insane
what's your name insanity what you mean
chess chess how old are you I'm actually
18
[ __ ]
does your mom drink wine bro
[Music]
I love it Gamecocks is that right nice
your Jericho Jericho [ __ ] contrary
baby fourth round round steel what can I
help you with bro bro I honestly this is
like absolutely insane like I feel like
I'm on cloud nine right now
I appreciate it when I saw this I was
like this is insanity
all right so what is the best best way I
can spread positivity around without
people trying to think like I'm like the
Charlotte day they're so like [ __ ]
type of guy you know what I mean I
couldn't I couldn't understand more the
what you need to do is just spread
positivity around and not listen to
anybody and let your history speak for
itself
yeah dude everybody like you don't
understand how many people didn't
believe in me my whole life that's the
majority when you do things that are
different or off the beam path you're
always underestimated all the people
that I know that are successful do
different things we all hear the murmurs
we all hear the cynicism we all hear the
doubt the difference is who can keep it
quiet in their own head and do their
thing
versus not like either you're full of
[ __ ] and you're not and that will play
out the reason I don't get too bothered
and I'm listen I can't I love to be
liked so when I get razzed it's not my
favorite thing but the only reason the
only reason I'm okay is I know what my
intent is and I know how it's gonna play
out so if you just don't listen to them
for the next decade you'll be fine I
really appreciate it Gary honestly I
feel like I just won the lottery
I appreciate it for a feeling bro I know
but if you don't text your [ __ ] uncle
right now with empathy wine is calm I'm
gonna [ __ ] die dude I love you too but
you better text every 21 year old with
empathy want like spam love everyone
Thank You Man thank you very much
thank you ocean I gotta go on again look
at this that must've been an hour or
something I got to go live again which
is good actually you got somebody else
all right
corporate gifts Gary Vee
komm flash gift I don't know if that's
up on the screen yet very nice for
corporate people need to get you in club
and hello it's Gary Vaynerchuk how are
you what's your what's your name my name
is odd
oz Lopez what up baby how are you
support my friends and family everybody
that I talk to anybody that's around me
I got a small port circle and you know
anything that can motivate me motivates
them and Thank You Man thank you brother
have a birthday thank you bro where do
you live in Miami Florida how old are
you oh I'm uh I'm 33 have you bought any
empathy wines yet I do thank you bro
thank you dude you need to also post it
on your Facebook and tell every [ __ ]
to buy it I'm going out right now I love
the man
what can I answer for you Oh Gary I just
wanted to say happy birthday man you
answered enough I got enough all your
arguments toodles out there for anybody
to find you just get inspired you know
right now I'm looking at trash talk I'm
looking at everything you know what I
mean you know saturday-morning stuff I'm
blowin up and I'm just so excited and
grateful and thank you man just
appreciative thank you I love you bro
thank you that's so nice now let me talk
to in screen for a second because we
just restarted this the feed Instagram
what is up
empathy whines calm let me let me put
this in here and pin it I would love
love love for you guys to support it I
just announced it if you're just joining
us my new direct-to-consumer wine
project that I've been working on for
over a year
super proud of it love to have you a
part of it
whoo Ben Ruby I just showed you here we
go pin all right please go to empathy
wines calm let me recap for everybody
who's watching or maybe just joining
earlier a couple hours ago I announced
my first my winery my winery that I have
with John and knee
and our unbelievable teammate Nora we
are selling a direct-to-consumer wine
business a rose a a white and a red the
reason I'm not tasting them is this is
dummy bottles our wine is still in
barrel the Rose a comes out in February
will it be I heard rumors at one point
that it might sneak in before
Valentine's Day
god damn it all right there goes my
entire theory but for st. Patty's Day
the greatest I just get it anyway there
was a comes out in late February early
March the white uh what's the we don't
have the final blend on the white right
we're still playing yeah I can't wait
for the red by the way the red real
quick I'm just gonna save time I'm just
gonna jump to it you probably think I'm
most excited about is how many people
are drinking a lot of great Reds out
there whether it's prisoner or other
things that nature we've cooked what
I've done with this project very
honestly and the team will tell you this
is where I got to impress Trouty a
little bit because he thought I was a
rusty wine guy my ability to reverse
engineer the American palate is real
it's very real I understand what the
consumer wants I'm like everybody that
drinks whispering angel rose' is gonna
[ __ ] their pants when they try empathy
rosey they're gonna realize that they
weren't in the minor leagues
I don't know so really say we should cut
that little piece that's a good piece of
I think you got that anyway nonetheless
just super excited for you to try it the
red is gonna blow people's faces off
who's this Sam it's Gary Vaynerchuk how
are you know did one one thing I gotta
leave the office real quick
yeah there's a real bro is what happens
when you put your full-time run your
school anyway get my bearing real quick
Gary first Hawk just want to say thank
you for everything you've done like I
respect the hustle heavily me my boys we
go out on the weekends out and we sell
garage sale so super dope you're amazing
thank you my just so my wife and my
uncle over in Seattle so you know what
are you doing I'm gonna give you all the
hype on Jays I gotta give you real love
are you telling me that we announced
this you then forwarded the information
to your uncle in Seattle and he bought
well yeah cause you were talking to the
other you know you're like so your uncle
I was like how am I gonna get
to talk to this guy right now like I'm
gonna show my uncle and send a picture
to the Gmail I did that and now you're
on the phone like bro I love hackers I
love people that understand is that how
they got und I love it man listen good
huh listen that's what I love about
karma like you can't imagine and you
know this cuz you're not old enough to
buy it but like you would have bought it
like when you give so much good in the
occasional once in a year thing when
somebody needs somebody and my big thing
the same thing with the sneakers like to
me it's like this if you buy sneakers
then I want your support on k-swiss like
if you buy wine I want your support on
empathy but if you don't drink wine or
more poorly even if you do I still don't
expect you to do it I'm just asking you
to do it and that's a big difference
from that's where everybody gets [ __ ]
up I'm putting out tons of content bro
do you know many people are watching
right now that have used my free advice
and of me tens and hundreds and millions
of dollars and will not buy empathy
there's so many
you can't bro I'm telling you this is
how life works I've been doing this a
long time there's an enormous amount of
people right now we're watching who
actually and they know in their heart
have benefited to the tune of tens and
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
will not give me seven hundred and
twenty bucks back as a thank you right
now and I'm saying this for real that's
why I'm saying it out loud
that's okay bye that's okay by me
I don't expect I'm not giving out there
with the expectation it's just it's just
the truth and that's where I think
people get [ __ ] up they give but it's
a loaded give oh do you understand all
right that's a good and it's a good
lesson for you to learn right now man if
you believe in my [ __ ] and jabbing and
all that just [ __ ] give leave it at
that
I just ran from a non-profit board meant
meeting I'm not on there like other
friends I have that are there to network
with the other high net-worth
individuals for a business outside the
non profit in that room I'm there to
give right I put out my content that
you're consuming you're fired up about
to give not because I think you're gonna
get your uncle to buy do I want you to
get your uncle to buy do I want you to
go get everybody in the office to buy
I'm trying to win but I don't expect and
that's where people get [ __ ] up yeah
all right real quick question don't
question why I got you go all right my
cell health insurance I know I'm 18
years old
I [ __ ] hate every second of it okay
yeah I do not like working for more an
entrepreneur I love dating [ __ ] yes but
I heard when you said don't be afraid to
eat [ __ ] to get where you want to go
right so I'm over here no no no let's
let's reframe it this why this is great
let's talk about eating [ __ ] what do you
want to be when you grow up so we're
like real [ __ ] right now I want to be I
want to I want to build skyscrapers and
like monument this day like some pretty
cool it like I just love buildings oh
cool so like like as I architect or as a
general contractor or as a developer
know like I just want like I want to
work with architects I can't draw how do
I do but I have like images in my head
let me tell you let me tell you let me
tell you what let me tell you what
eating [ __ ] is and in garyvee mindset
you should I should go home tonight and
Google the 50 best architects in the
world you should find them on social
media on the web and you should DM them
and email them and tell them that you
will work for free as their second admin
because you're so hungry and passionate
about what you do one of the 50 of them
will say yes then you have to get the
[ __ ] Madrid live somewhere for free
and eat
d-roc how when you were working out of
Starbucks in your early grind how much
money on food did you spend a day less
than $10 and where did you live in the
sisters basement of San Island I want
you to find the 50 best architects in
the world I want you to DM them on
Instagram if they're on their email them
a LinkedIn if they're their email the
info page of their architect business
find them write the most variation in
truth of why you should work for them
for free pick up their [ __ ] laundry
get working at an insurance company to
make money is an eating [ __ ] when that's
not your goal your [ __ ] needs to be in
what you want to be one day your goal in
life is to get to the Sun get
to the Sun you need to work for free for
free as admin number four in turn number
63 for the guy or gal that you want to
be like when you grow up and you need to
live the shittiest [ __ ] life because
you have nine [ __ ] roommates that you
found on Craigslist in a fucked-up
neighborhood all right okay I want to be
an architect but you how to [ __ ] do I
explain this to you I wish I could just
email you're not wasting my time brother
all right I give you right now listen to
me fine you don't to be an architect
cool
who the [ __ ] does what you do and if you
say nobody you're gonna lose then you
need to figure out who that is and then
go work for her for free all right dude
working for free for the person is
[ __ ] amazing
it will change your life if you're good
all right I need to find out who I need
your work for free though good go have
fun and sell and but wait and now text
your other aunt too because the uncles
good in Seattle but I want your aunt
Mississippi - I got it yeah they're
gonna have to give you wine let's go Jay
person appreciate my man thank you all
right what's been happening Nate are we
selling wine slower a little slower
I don't like slower five minutes ago I
don't like slower that we need like
6,000 we're not even in the game this is
this is well what happened was Nate
wasn't ready and we lost [ __ ] all the
action we lost all four thousand we're
gonna like you ruined everything
you got a corporate gift there I love it
the number you had
that would be a very basic smart idea
hello hi it's Gary Vaynerchuk I cannot
believe thank you happy birthday Gary
thank you so much what's your name my
name is Alexandra Alexandra thank you so
much so you have a corporate gift
concept I mortgage specialist in
Montreal for one of the biggest banks in
Canada okay so my question was I think
you did mention that you don't get
shipped to Canada that's right so that's
good because you said in the summer that
is correct
awesome would like to give us my clients
I guess once you know they take a
mortgage with me something almost like a
an incentive that I'd like to give out I
love it share on my social media
definitely you're amazing so email email
Jonn J'onzz calm and we'll get it all
figured out hang on I'm writing this
down because I'm organized that way I
got already done this by that question I
love it so yep jo-ann yeah at empathy
wines calm okay and for the cases you
said it was if it's one case is a twenty
bottle so here's how it works they we
sell them in subscriptions you can buy
the 3-pack the six pack or the twelve
pack and you get twelve bottle you get
three six or twelve bottles and you get
the Rose a the white the red and they
come out at different times in the year
so if you buy the three pack you get
three Rose a in February or March
you get three white in June you get
three red in October
okay that's correct that's right up a
box as people say wine is 12 a case you
know wine and so that's 12 pack and if
you buy if you buy a case of each you
get put into Club empathy which is the
one that gives you the SMS service and
helps you with any wine needs at all
times which is what probably I'd be more
interested in that's the one that's
about 720 right that's correct
I'm gonna need a lot of details sorry I
know I'm here for you
check that out and it is a subscription
that renews automatically every year or
is that at some point that we get the
option to not that I want to stop it but
we it does automatically renew but we
over communicate when that process is
about to happen so nobody feels that
they got tricked into reoccurring okay
perfect isn't we're gonna get receipt
for that yep that's awesome
I love you finish thank you thank you
well listen I glad glad to be able to
share this fun my social video also time
oh yeah thank you so much follow me if
you'd like it Alexandra chorus RBC on
Instagram
why don't you DM me and start the
sentence with I'm the lady from
entrepreneur
the lady from Canada buying the
corporate gifts I'll find any my DMS and
I'll follow you perfect thanks so much
you gotta ask you for one more favor
sure my friend of mine is named Angelo
actually like probably your biggest best
you were exact company called my visa
Montreal
my geek didn't give him a yeah - and
when shelvings Angelo just give a quick
shout-out you got it thank you so much
Angelo from mine geek in Montreal I
[ __ ] love your face all right there's
a shout out
I'm a he's like I want to go to
Instagram all right Nate yeah we do want
to do the 4d stuff what is that
that is the if you buy right yes so I
wanted to do in this launch a couple
things I want to make sure everybody's
watching I'm doing the club empathy
giveaway anybody who buys club empathy
right now which is seven hundred twenty
bucks amortized over three payments to
forty next year which is a case of each
when you buy it we're printing out your
name and information I'm gonna pull one
in forty minutes one name and I'm flying
you to New York to have dinner so I'm
excited about that before these thing
I'm debating is if people buy 42
packages 42 cases so that's what 14
packages that's the cost of 40s so I've
been thinking about I don't know if I
want to do it right but if you buy you
buy 14 packages you get four DS for free
which is basically spend 10,000 to get
20,000
thinking about it how many people here
in the comments are considering four DS
you know we're raising the price of
forties yeah how many people watching
right now know what the vaynermedia for
DS thing is and are considering it if I
see ten or fifteen then am I just
activated and do a little birthday gift
for you guys so we got to figure it out
oh that's the live stuff yeah let me let
me read alive
I'm so happy thank you so much affect me
prime fly media thank you the way it's
selling it should be Club empathy Oh
club birthday Karen thanks so much thank
you Jenny
appreciate it birthday text my pleasure
put your foot down take down crap four
DS for short Vince is considering it not
sure what it is you raise the price
we're going to be raising it I love you
brother I love you back wiki traitor we
should go to four degrees could we buy
wine from Bitcoin not yet but that's
something what I really want to do I'm
eighty nine forty five thousand bucks in
the bank you should buy their fourteen
packages of empathy that's yeah why
don't you link with four DS is alright
let's get another phone call going recap
for everybody my new winery is launched
empathy wines super excited about it
really really really excited about it
rose a white and red the ultimate $40
wine for twenty bucks when you buy into
club empathy Club empathy is when you're
able to get the SMS service above and
beyond let's actually convert into
birthday before you get the doll my
friend a time Sugarman is here and he
has my birthday present I want to open
it no I don't wanna do it live all right
let's move on go ahead
well the only bite your reaction like I
don't save it sneaker fam good to see
you Axl thank you for being here guys if
I brought you any and he and Joey Fatone
the legend said Kelly anytime I said hi
in sync mafia hello its Gary Vaynerchuk
who's this hey hey man how are you good
life is good bro how you been gonna be
better
that makes me super happy what's cooking
nothing much man
one a lot as soon as this whole lying
thing going on you know I got ten years
sober but I want to buy some red for a
whole call Benandonner the yellow and
red colors I love man you're amazing
what was your favorite wrestler of all
time Rene I actually prefer to arch the
animals yo fat the animal Georgie animal
steals all time don't have any animal
stealing I thought I did
is that was a you know what's funny
about that that [ __ ] with me a little
bit because you know he was a pretty
bitter rival of [ __ ] Randy the Macho
Man Savage and I don't like that he
pushed me off the top rope and let ricky
the dragon' pin me then lose my
Intercontinental title I got a little
beef with George the animal Steele
driving crazy distracted start getting
the foam post that I know there's gonna
get bad picked after that where do you
think that match steamboat and savage
wrestle maybe three right all-time that
was three right that was three versus
three what what do you think that fits
all time in matches like all time I got
you realize that in the top five
I mean they were after really cool
ability what they were able to soon
unbelievable all-time unbelievable but
go figure right how do I wind up in
Georgia I mostly open and I want to
working with Balkan Rick out of all
people but I think yeah yeah over here
favorite oh I'm Macho Man is my first
second and third favorite wrestler ball
time I also was huge on the missing link
I also like how I also like how the
one-man gang became Akeem the African
dream when slick did that weird like
thing on Saturday morning and converted
him from the one-man gang into Akeem the
African dream that was Braun was was
interesting to me as well I don't
understand it why why is Rey Mysterio so
popular long after my generation what
would something with him he [ __ ] flew
around the ring like he flew around the
ring raised amazing he was amazing I
wish he was during my prime you know you
know what used to
[ __ ] with me as I watched all wrestling
so I would watch ESPN and watch like the
Texas [ __ ] then I would watch like you
know TBS and watch the NWA and flair
nose boys and the four horsemen and WWF
and when I was a real little kid I would
freak when a person would come to the
WWF from some warehouse right like The
Ultimate Warrior I'll never forget that
I'm like is that the Dingle warrior like
that stuff used to be amazing or like
when Terry Taylor came up at me I'm like
he's not the Red Rooster and he don't
like that stuff he said I still love
that [ __ ] yeah is it a special time man
we grew up in the heyday of it all be
really good dude it was nice to talk to
you man thanks for calling bro talk to
you um all right let's keep ask
questions for evening in the pans call
me the legend killer yeah awesome
can we get the need yeah me get some
face time people wanna know who you know
after you know well you didn't mess it
up you just destroyed everything
actually I Adam four DS while Nate's
getting some face time 40s as the daily
digital deep dive it's a one-day
consulting session at vaynermedia that
has become monumental it lacks a ton of
people have taken it they pay their 10k
the business goes from 2 million to 5
millions become a little bit legendary
it's become a huge thing at vaynermedia
packed classes high demand pretty cool
hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk who's this hey
how are you very good how are you man oh
thank you bro thank you so much what's
going on well I just joined the forties
Club thank you I run the chain of
restaurants in materials we have a
counter service of organic vegan
restaurants meeting amazing how many 6
we have 6 locations we want to go nation
international and and we want to we want
to be adding the alcohol okay I'll go
where are you where are you ready to
Canada and very very soon can you email
are you on the desktop yes I am do you
see the little chat thing on the right
bottom right I'm on Facebook
hmm if you go to empathy wines calm
there's a little bit fat on the bottom
and okay just give your information
there or email john jo n at empathy
wines calm anybody watching just email
John and John at empathy wines calm he's
ready to take your money or answer your
question or help you in any way he can
fantastic I won't ask you how do you
think social media can help restaurant
well watch you get out of here watch
this a time come up here I mean this is
just real life you have an incredible
restaurant in Midtown right hunting fish
club yeah you're my best bud happy
birthday to me thank you I'm glad you're
here tell us fine gentlemen your journey
with social media we've been friends a
long time you know over the last six
months to become obvious to you that it
does work versus having times where stop
and start just getting the full story
like from your perspective how does it
work honestly not only did I realize it
worked I gotta admit that I was not
necessarily a believer in the beginning
my restaurants were having a little bit
of a lag I really want to get the
message out about how great the food was
and the service was I came to Gary and I
asked him for a favor to help navigate
me and my team to really get the most
out of social media and to brand
ourselves effectively and his wonderful
team and and the character right here
and shows that show those beautiful
faces right they started work with your
team they've been working with our team
selflessly just out of love and I gotta
say we've seen a 12% increase this year
and my partner Nelson is a biggest
skeptic of all time first one to say
this is all as a result of the marketing
that the Vayner team has done for us so
it's a great thing because we've really
gotten the message out that you know
this is such a special place and so many
people maybe never would have seen our
place and every beauty bubble on the
chat hon fish is the best steakhouse in
New York City you bro thank you so yeah
it's it's such a great thing and it's
such a great gift and it's because you
know ultimately we're all in the
business of getting our message out
right people what what is that we do so
I gotta tell you I mean for the last
call it was in the restaurant business
you know what an increase like that is
and I attribute it in great part if not
entirely
to this kind of market yes so thank you
meup it's big yeah so bro listen it's
where the attention is it's no different
than cable television commercials or
smoke signals back in the day or Direct
Mail you just have to follow attention I
think social could be the biggest
biggest biggest impact on your business
once you know how to do it right I
completely agree the thing I mean the T
I'm struggling with is following up on
what kind of what kind of traction you
actually get like how many people
actually see it and how many people
actually count because in terms of
building brand there we don't have the
budget for it so we're trying to kind of
convert into people are walking through
the door all you have to do is tell your
six bartender you have a bar do you have
bartenders no I don't count as heavy so
we're like it fast got it ready create a
secret menu item that doesn't exist
something you're considering to make
exists only promote that on social media
and tell them the only way they can get
it is when they come into the restaurant
to ask for it and then see how many you
sold that day and 64 people asked for
the supersalty pasta and now you know 64
[ __ ] came from Facebook do you
understand yeah listen there's always a
way if that's what you want to happen if
you that's how you do it secret menu
item only promote it through social
media look at how many were sold now you
know how the $297 in facebook ads
performed based on how many people water
did that day make sense no sir
well next time you're in mojo can have
the best falafel yeah we've been was
seven years running before the Mojo so
it don't ask next time you and your
buddy thank you brother thanks for
calling that's that good stuff I don't
want you falafels I don't owe your gifts
I want you to buy empathy wines calm if
you're watching right now empathy wines
calm that's what I'm looking for that's
what I want thank you for the birthday
wishes Christopher Gonzalez thank you so
much thank you so much Tom K Eric
drawers I appreciate you
let's go to Facebook Jake Ari oh thank
you so much Shalini Elizabeth thank you
so much empathy wines calm if I brought
you any value ever
empathy wines calm please buy it would
mean the world to me we have weight less
orders that I wanted I blame it all on
Nate for losing the first 20 minutes of
energy Sam looks like looks like we're
going
No okay got it
who's this what what's up Instagram
thank you so much for the birthday
wishes appreciate you guys so much
Chandra thank you so much yo its Gary
Vaynerchuk how are you oh you gotta be
kidding me what's up Gary
Jeff life is good bro where you from man
Springfield Illinois happy birthday
buddy dude do you know how [ __ ] thank
you bro do you know pumped I am about
being able to ship wine to Illinois
finally oh he's pretty cool huh
I'm [ __ ] fired up wow that's awesome
what can I help you with broke we'll
check it out I got I sell cars here yep
for a Chevrolet dealership okay
understood
and we also own a Honda dealership right
next door I'm listening but so with
their Corvettes and stuff like that
spring the Chevrolet Susan's Auto Mall
what I want to do is on our Corvettes
and stuff like that maybe offer
something such as your wine bro that
means the world to me as a matter of
fact if you email John at empathy wines
calm John jo-ann if you guys commit to
enough I'll even make a video that you
guys can play every time somebody buys
one to two like really nail home the
kind of exclusivity of it sure love it
thanks for watching my stuff man
how long you been watching it I watch it
all the time I check out everything
thank you bro how long do you keep up
you taught me a lot in a lot of
different ways you know thank you bro
thank you bro yeah when did you first
become aware of my stuff uh a couple
years now Facebook yeah love it thank
you bro fear are you do work are you a
Bulls fan yeah well [ __ ] how old are you
I'm gonna be 45 next month oh [ __ ] so
you really went through that whole er
huh oh yeah with Jordan as a boy's
matter okay yeah it was really [ __ ]
great love you bro thank you for calling
hey you gotta do he was [ __ ] like
partying and loving life I'm like crying
in my bedroom
[ __ ] hated that era man I cry
yeah that was the worst [ __ ] hate
Jordan alright let me give some more
Lola thank you so much
Eric Eric see thank you for buying to
clubs
thank you so much everybody in facebook
chat right now please tell me yes or no
if you bought empathy wines and the nose
matter to me because I'm trying to get
data like you won't hurt my feelings I
totally get it
it would mean the world to me if you did
yes know how many people bought the club
empathy so I can understand the drawing
hello who's this
Gary what up right like this good man
who's this
it's hobby man have your strategies for
Miami ice man how are you man I live off
your model my friend three years ago I'm
going to pictures of scoop right now man
three years ago I started with $300 in
the bank I have followed you from day
one and I promise you man you're one of
my idols my friends and now we're
setting 23.7 million dollars today year
guys no clapping for Xavier the natural
progression from that statement is hobby
how many [ __ ] cases of empathy wines
are you buying
I appreciate make it six or nine hobby
goal on calming down
it's gotta be six or nine you got either
by two club member these or three club
ever these seven cases is a weird number
in the way we sell it so are you in for
- club empathise with six cases are you
in for three club empathise for nine
cases I mean with oh you rock you lost
that bet
do you oculata I appreciate it bro Nate
I just gave up the case thank you honey
but my sales guys know I got filled out
in the field to sell air conditions for
all day long yep the thing is how do I
get them to because I'm really good
pretty much at studying and yeah I've
been following you for a while yep how
do I get my guys to to get at that level
should I ride with them consistently
that I show on the trip so I suppose
that I don't matter how to sell how to
communicate with a customer what what do
I need to do my friend yes
thing you just said but more importantly
how many do you have I have right now
about pigtails go you need to take them
out to dinner one by one and spend three
hours with them and get to know them and
understand what they're good at what
they're bad at and what they want out of
life and this job your number one job
Row is to work for them not have them
work for you you need to build an actual
relationship and find out are they
motivated by money what if one of them
is a huge Miami Dolphins fan and now you
buy him tickets to the 50-yard line and
now he's got an owie knows that you care
about him and now he sells two times
better what if you find out that his
wife has a sec or her husband has a
second job and Fridays have been
difficult and now you tell him to stay
home on Fridays but kill it Monday
through Thursday you need to build a
relationship so that you could reverse
engineer the six of them I'm trying to
reverse engineer nine hundred people
I'm sure six sounds like a bargain do
you see what I mean honey because then
we're gonna build then they're gonna
care about you because you cared about
them first
you got you got it another thing my kids
follow you too my friend my god a 15
year old and I have a five year old
remember you trash your trappings on
Sunday they just started last week
they're 15 year old and I got an 8 year
old and they make in within one week
that makes $661 by themselves my
grandkids 15 you're not an angel to have
a stuff hobby every day I read people
leaving comments on my YouTube and
Facebook of why this doesn't work why
I'm wrong why you can't why I know
brother brother I know it is man the
stories like this mean the world to me
especially all the people that are
listening and watching right now it
matters somebody right now was just like
wait a minute eight year old Lisa Souter
books like buying that garage sales are
they selling ship that they have in the
room
some days to do stuff with them right
now you know like they're selling their
own stuff man stuff that they don't use
them getting rid of it man don't want to
buy a BMX bike you want to get some
stuff suits off I do themselves I think
you might get your responsibility then
to have to have enum havi go buy a nice
state dinner and get to know your six
sales people it will change your
business I'm gonna do it a hundred
percent again your stuff works man I
don't kill anybody my hobby you don't
buy the [ __ ] six cases of wine right
now and I don't see your name all right
well love you brother thank you so much
man thank you thank you I know we're
gonna talk I'm sorry I'm sorry I gotta
bang this out and I'm not gonna rush out
when I leave anyway cool
all right let's keep this going Alma
thank you so much Marda great to see you
thank you so much let's do this Bobby
Baba Baba Baba what a great name happy
birthday thank you so much
Devante thank you so much Vince Fanning
what seeing and yang I don't know I got
this as a gift this morning I think it's
just the macro brand no wine for now no
problem that doesn't bother me at all
thank you so much
Neeta Paul Mills thank you so much let's
go here the Instagram DL bead thank you
so much for the birthday wish
Nate JM thank you so much Aaron prime
fly company thank you so much
need a corporate gift that stuff I saw
that in the chat
Johnny how we doing we gettin answers
you guys helping you guys doing all your
customer service thing Nate who's this
hello hi hey Robert yeah
can you turn down the can you turn down
us on the back yeah how you doing Robert
good how are you
amazing what are you from awesome are
you how old are you come on you're
Patriots fan huh oh for sure respect all
right what's up nothing man just wanna
say happy birthday and I don't drink
wine but I picked up a 30 pack and gonna
give it to my girlfriend
someone and then I'll give you some to
our mom to dude honestly on a very
serious note like I really appreciate
that like that really really genuinely
and I want you hearing from like my soul
that means a lot to me thank you
you're welcome thank you and I
appreciate the trash-talking Pro now
that I get out a few back so far and
what was your bestie what was your best
flip oh I got something I was saying yes
but I've been doing my gos so 20 30
bucks
yeah like thank you yeah Legos are huge
I'm so devastated it's the winter right
now and we don't have town wide and
garage sales so we're gonna have to do
some flea markets we got to figure it
out I'm gonna try to bang out one in
Vegas during the first week of January
like I got a hack a little bit right now
but um but I really appreciate I can't
wait to get crying again Friday estate
sales are money
Friday estate sales that's the hack dude
thank you one more time it means the
world to me that you picked up a three
pack no problem thank you for your
content you got it brother three pack
three pack three pack club empathy for
everybody joining right now on Instagram
Facebook empathy wines calm I announced
my new winery direct-to-consumer winery
brand I'm super excited about it it's a
big big deal to me it would mean the
world to me if you joined it would be a
enormous birthday present to me if you
bought if you buy the club empathy which
is a case of each you get the SMS
service where we answer your wine
questions at all time but more
importantly during this live stream only
you get entered in we're about to print
out a bunch of names I'm gonna pick one
name and somebody buys Club up with you
right out of 720 bucks absolutely then
gets flown out to here and have dinner
with me in New York if you if you're in
LA then I'll just go to LA and meet you
we'll figure it out pull up dinner
together in 2019 how we doing hey Julie
waters
Walters Julie Walters thank you so much
three Club empathise it's huge you know
what is going on twitch speak to the
People's Choice Awards bus the Freestyle
I can't rap like that Muhammad good to
see t walk good to see you do we ship to
you
or no no Utah no Utah no Mississippi no
Arctic's are all aware hotel aware in
Rhode Island
ooh Julie Walters there she is
I bought Club empathy you sure did Julie
you mean the world to me for that thank
you so much for that support
empathy wines calm at minimum of three
pack would mean the world to me please
please please support the new project
really would appreciate it what do you
got I love it Christmas presents I love
it if you're looking for corporate gifts
Gary Vee comm slash gift I bought a
three pack for you just now thank you
lead back if you're buying please leave
comments in here I want to say thank you
yes to Florida we love yo it's Gary Vee
really yes sir Travis needs a vacation
and we do ship to Tennessee right Travis
we're in I see you up there
yeah what's your name bro I'm Joe man
Joe what are you from I'm down in
Florida happy birthday thank you so much
man how old are you I'm [ __ ] chapter
26 yeah Joe are you are you in for
[ __ ] empathy wines are you [ __ ]
breaking my heart I'm I'm a didn't count
I'm sharing it I'm sure I'm gonna be
buying some people so Christmas presents
my guy thank you so much what can I
answer for you
so I'm actually working in the health
industry filling out my own company and
everything and we cannot advertise
except locally I mean where's the social
media and even social media is tricky
I'm very where influencers and a podcast
if you're in cannabis and hemp right now
influencers and a podcast that's my two
biggest recommendations that's what I've
been working on trance I still get
influenced using don't try go go hard
like that is like there is no try when
you're this restricted it's you're
expanding yeah it's it's not spamming
it's looking at their account seeing how
you can bring them value and writing
something meaningful 2006 for 2011
I lived on Twitter reply to everybody
everybody
long before anybody knew who I was or
this is how I got here I put in the
[ __ ] work
for every day going to sleep two three
four o'clock in the morning would sleep
six or seven or eight hours cuz I go
into Wine Library later because those
were the years where I would answer
every email and reply start a show find
influencers grind if you wanted that bad
I'll start a show thank you for working
getting enclosures I'm gonna get more
good luck brother that's a real one
thank you for the support bro thank you
here we go here we go
how did my card and I said no
Mississippi god damn it that hurts
what do we need to do I heard something
about 750 Chris Becker go to empathy
wines calm if you buy Club empathy at
7:20 you get a case abuse yes John
Kickstarter video for them mmm way too
many me being in a kick
yeah thousand dollars worth of Club
Anthony yes sir thank you bro what's
your name Jay Johnson jr. Jay Johnson
jr. where you from
Akron Ohio how old are you I am 33 years
old and entrepreneur since I was about
this working I love Excel Jay I love it
great great can't believe I'm [ __ ]
you so check this out okay so I'm going
to start document right Jeremy yes I'm
really good at making things look at it
so we'll be here with my video editing
skills cue me so nervous
yeah well trouble joke there should be a
reason to be nervous I'm sensing that
you have not bought empathy wines yet
true or not don't lie know if the truth
is good reason damn good reason how's
that tell me you know I got a letter for
my facebook Instagram at this particular
part of the journey
iris no my question is how do I feel
like my journey in context in the right
context what does that mean to you Tina
volumes they did you join a club empathy
I feel like I think I want to do what
you do I feel like I get the most value
from that and I think I can deliver that
to you know people like me so then just
put it away be a different way this is
good then just put it out on on Facebook
and YouTube okay that's
yeah there's no jokes the content
ultimately creates the context right
right makes it great you know what I
mean just [ __ ] put it out
perfect perfect will of you I got a
brother keyboard he tricked you with
$10,000 right you feel tricked right my
trouble jail you're so some man you're
smart uh Mike Schoonover thank you so
much it will be available in Portugal
Victor in the summer internationals
happening this summer everybody on
Facebook Jordan thank you so much Dr
Neal thank you so much miss lady to you
thank you for the birthday gift
what wish excuse me love you back miss
Jenny MA Renato thank you so much how we
doing Nate with sales slowdown we're
doing well we're picking up I really
appreciate it a little bit later yep
may be joining in thank you guys so much
everybody who's buying please go to
empathy wines calm and support a three
pack a six pack at welcome Nicole this
is Gary Vaynerchuk Gary how are you
well I'm 43 and I need to sell 30,000
cases of wine and we've sold like six so
I'm a little stressed thank you no
honestly I'm honestly I'm so grateful
you bought what I would say for
everybody watching on Instagram Facebook
everywhere just sharing the URL on
social media would mean a lot to me so
many people drink wine and like it's
just I don't know it's 40 [ __ ] dollar
wine for 20 bucks it's a good idea to
buy yeah thank you what did you buy did
you buy a three pack subscription Oh
baby art I'm the club is the best are
you gonna use it like are you gonna tech
are you gonna text us and be like I need
to buy a bottle for my boss or I'm going
to Sonoma like are you gonna use it I've
gotta do that thank you thank you what
can I answer for you and thank you so
you you really can't imagine you kidding
I really mean this I want you to hear
this you can't imagine how much it means
to me
that you bought the club empathy thing
I'm really excited about it I think you
would be blown away by the wine I can't
wait for you to like give it to people
and they'll be like oh my god that's
amazing
how do I get it like then you'll tell
the story it's just gonna be it's gonna
be so fun to build this for me like I
when I heard about this I thought oh man
I hope they can afford it I want to be
able to buy it I wanted to do it for you
but I also knew it's gonna be awesome
for me but thank you for making it
affordable that I could do it
thank you is there anything I can answer
before you go yeah so one of my planet
so I thank you for helping me and
everyone I started watching three years
ago two years ago I was self-employed
and I'm I did the first six months where
I was working full time getting up from
5:00 to 7:00 in the morning and then you
in the 7 to 2 in the evening I did that
for 6 months now in full time welcome
for so thank you and my I do
I just musicians primarily for nonprofit
it's working but it's totally working
yes and one of my clients they hit their
league goal by the end of the third
quarter so for the year so like just
another one of my clients they doubled
attendance at at their fundraisers six
months I mean it I'm super I'm super
aware this everything I'm spinning for
free works yeah it's right that's why
I'm I expect every person watching right
now to go to empathy wines calm and by
club empathy is there anything is there
anything else I can add yep for this
line today I figured s was coming and I
wanted to be able to do a wine tasting
and I wanted your tips on how do I make
this wine tasting memorable I know the
wines memorable but how do I make it
memorable what do I do
I got an idea the most memorable way to
make a wine tasting happen is to do a
brown-bag tasting so you
tastes a bunch of wines and brown bags
and let people rate them and an unveil
it at the end it's the most fun okay so
maybe you brought maybe you bring
empathy and maybe you have other people
bring their own wine and maybe you bring
some other wines and I love that because
then when empathy wins the tasting blind
you'll realize how great it is I know
I'm gonna take advantage of it thank you
for doing this thank you so much darling
thank you so much that was so sweet
she's awesome there's a bunch of
questions Nate John Nora tomorrow you to
be very busy every single comment in
Facebook needs to be CMD cuz there's a
lot of question you know how you doing
over there give us a little update yeah
what are you getting a lot of what yep
yep
what's happening there what are people
asking yeah yeah let me repeat that for
everybody I know a lot of people just
jumping in I announced my winery
it's a direct-to-consumer winery it's
called empathy whoever has the most
empathy for the farmers and you the
consumer I think wins how do we make the
farmers famous and how do I use that
leverage to get the prices down and
eliminate the distributors and the
retailers and the restaurants and go
directly to you my dream was to make the
best $20 wine destroy whispering angel
and every other Rose a beat out the
prisoner and all those other bootleg and
all those projects create the ultimate
white wine that blows away the Sancerre
and Chardonnay and Pine Ridge Chenin
Blanc drinker that is what we've done
we've got something called Club empathy
which is what you add this to the
equation if you buy a case of each you
get join to the club which gives you an
SMS capability where you can text us at
all times and we will service your why
needs need other gifts need to get to a
winery need tips tricks need to take a
picture of a menu and have us help you
pick your wine whatever you can use and
need it is the ultimate wine experience
you can buy in packs we sell them in
three six or twelve packs if you buy
three or six you're not part of Club
empathy when you buy 12 you're part of
Club apathy when you buy from us now you
get billed right away for Jose which
comes in February when the white and red
come out that's when you get billed for
those that is the project all the
information is on empathy wines calm and
everybody watching go watch the bid
on empathy whines calm which is a lot of
fun we made a great little video also if
you can't afford or you're too young to
buy wine if you can share empathy wines
calm on your social media right now that
would mean a lot to me if I brought you
any value you can't imagine more than
the sneakers more than the books this is
the one for me this is the one if you
want to give me a birthday present
buying a three pack especially by having
12 pack and then finally Gary Vee comm
slash gift I think this is the craziest
corporate gift why because I'm a
salesman and a businessman why because
when you buy this as a gift we send a
nice little invitation at home that to
the person which they get for the
holidays but then more importantly they
get wine in February they get wine in
June they get wine in October which
reinforces your relationship with them
which creates the serendipity to do more
business and that's what corporations
want so so we're excited about it that
was super concise that was tight yes
[ __ ] yeah
now please buy the wine if you if you
drink wine if you drink wine like
actually let me make it very simple
if you drink wine please buy the three
pack subscription it's nine bottles a
year you're getting ridiculous $40 plus
wine for 27 bucks when you buy three yes
so it's 27 25 and 20 yes
maybe people should really buy Club em
to me I really think you should buy Club
empathy that's right we had a beta user
Balan soon nor they were blown away like
they were pumped daven gaga
got it okay let's do another phone call
I really if you bought club empathy if
you bought wine give us tons of value we
should be you give us tons of violet we
should all be buying 30 cases of peace I
agree oh like have you bought so logic
have you bought 30 cases we will be
shipping this wine in the US there are
four or five states that we can't ship
to know Delaware Rhode Island
Mississippi Arkansas
Utah al no Alabama's good that's those
right Arkansas and we will be going
international this summer we have
enormous demand for international and
we'll be doing that this summer
can't wait now some of the shipping
maybe more than one itself but if you're
in Germany or in Holland or Portugal
just having it first of all the fact
that we have 20 bucks
built-in factor you're actually getting
$4 wine it's kind of cool because it
might be as much as 20 bucks a bottle
shipping yeah it's gonna be gnarly but
it's gonna be rare like if you're like
the og that has it in like Germany not
just gonna be fresh all right we're
gonna do a phone call I just want to
thank people that are buying it
anybody buying it please leave a comment
means the world just a 3-pack 3-pack
would mean the world to me don't give
them an option just sell the club
triumph like I want to get people to
three bottle option and a six I want a
partner B therapy thing wine scary and
investment in Shem so you know I know
you your wife is just signed up with
Boehner speakers we can talk about it
hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk how are you
yeah Roger what up real quick hold on
one second
guys we have three minutes left I need
you guys printing I don't know what
you're doing oh we're good
all right where we've got real quickly
drew give me one second you've got three
minutes left three minutes to go to club
empathy by club empathy we're printing
out all the receipts right now I'm gonna
pick one name from a hat I'm gonna have
dinner with you in 2019 if you buy Club
empathy in the next three minutes which
means a case of each that's a 720
package I would love that
what's up bro how are you I am fantastic
I was actually outside in the cold
unloading a truckload of glass plated
for Whole Foods across the US and I
heard my phone ringing and I said to
Lisa I understand
Gary calling me and I ran off the park
inaudible that is unbelievable how are
you fantastic so we're we finally got
the national listing at at Whole Foods
took me only 18 years I'm so proud of
you we met nine years ago
you make incredible products the best
[ __ ] pasta sauce ever
I'm such a fan of you that I'm such a
fan of yours
I so appreciate the relationship over
the last decade and I'm just just so
nice to hear your voice especially in a
special day for me yeah
thank you bro yeah I mean we haven't
talked for ages but you know the
influence that you have on the out of
daily basis and you know listening to
your podcast every day's will be a 10-15
minute drive home the fact that's all I
listen to now I feel like an [ __ ] for
getting a good stereo system I don't buy
gum [ __ ] and you know I just I'm keeping
my fingers crossed that we can do
something more significant yeah yeah
it's just a matter here just a matter of
time
Thank You Man I'm just I'm really glad
to n with you have a great day so yeah I
got a brother um all right
what's up doesn't work for me connection
timeout how we did with the website good
feel good all right good
overall so I'm cleaning up the day one
yeah not bad for day one all right we're
gonna get the receipts now I'm gonna
give my last plea cuz I got a balance
it's my birthday and I'm gonna bounce
for my birthday I'm super happy about
this I'm gonna go on a bunch I'm gonna
change my signature I'm gonna change my
Twitter and Instagram URLs it's all now
empathy wines if you didn't you know it
would mean a lot to me if you could by
tonight as you can imagine I'm gonna
make all my strategies based on what we
sell right now so I have to figure that
out corporate gifts big part of what I
want to do but uh I'm super super super
flattered by anybody who's supported I
really really really really appreciate
all of you thank you so much I can't
wait to do this drawing how many people
do we have how many people are in club
empathy how many names am i drawing from
you think really oh Sweden nicely people
really stepped up even though you
destroyed us I would say I got us here
Andy something Michael
I think Nate's thinking in the microwave
[Laughter]
I'm buy 500 cases no joke this is the
best wine deal in the world
[ __ ] the mini man long live empathy
hashtag proud investor Mike Lazar al
he's the best last I'm so glad you're
watching I love you bro
Mike Lazaro one of the best
entrepreneurs in the game many of you
have heard the story back in the day I
always talk about buddy media what a one
of the if not the great social media
companies of of the world I'm in an
office right now the size of the
conference room that Mike Lazaro that
Mike Lazaro from Buddy Media graciously
gave to AJ night for free our first you
want to about entrepreneurship our first
four to six months we didn't pay rent
when everyone's like oh you were here we
didn't have money to pay rent then Ruby
we started a company in the conference
room of Buddy Media cats Mike's wife
unbelievable operator that was a true
partnership I don't I think it's more
cast of Mike built an incredible company
when all said and done with the stock
price a billion dollar exit the
Salesforce three of the best kids in the
world two of the best humans at the top
of that family true family to me an
investor in empathy as you two wonderful
people this is the best so how is it all
right no photo I'm going to look as I do
this drawing this is it good medals
receipts this feels like 100 I'm gonna
try to mix it up I don't want it like
somebody bought first or last and mix up
I'm gonna pull a name and I can't wait
to have dinner with you based on last
charity Sam can you believe this eighty
thousand dollars then dinner with me
this is eighty thousand dollar value
here for 720 that was a good deal Sam I
actually willing to have dinner with you
sometimes think about that so like when
we watch check games at the tailgate
that's probably like a twenty thousand
dollar value I'm gonna bill you next
week yeah how'd you find out oh I got to
talk to you about the restaurant thing
do you see the incredible news for resi
big shout out to resi yeah acquisition
of reserved that's a big big moment
when a huge shout out to Mike Montero
and Ben Leventhal ex Ben Leventhal sees
oh dude it's it's resin is like
unbelievable what they've accomplished
like so much pride to what they've done
Dan Cox purchased Club empathy thank you
so much
empathy genes we need to create a club
d-roc I want to design I'm in club
empathy logo and I want to post it and
let people post in their social media
and it will track it and Andy the big
push is coming now alright cuz all this
stuff is nothing to push on email and
text so that'll be interesting so really
you want me to sit here like do not go
home for your birthday okay nice like
orders are coming in I don't want you to
leave you alright here it is here we go
here's the winner let me tell you this
is the winner let me tell you he's not
the winner I love doing this the second
runner-up who gets nothing but just
their name mentions now this is
devastating it is very devastating no I
know this breaks my heart to know this
is really sad the runner up you know
it's really sad bit you were very close
ready
and here just Lynette Morrison Lynette
so close sorry Lynette but I love you
alright the winner
Lynette's in health and she's in
California which would have been nice I
could have just done in LA now this
characters would be like him like Iowa
here we go
the winner of the club empathy
livestream giveaway to have dinner with
me next year and by the way I'm gonna be
charismatic and smart over to sinner I'm
gonna be really good I'm gonna top notch
I'm not I'm gonna definitely showered
Tyler not here but I'm sure you're
listening we're not gonna do it 11:30
p.m. slot right you know like this would
be a solid 7 8 o'clock 8:30 8:30 to
10:30
the winner is James Davis Noblesville
Indiana James congratulations thank you
so much for supporting Oh James I'm
pumped James I'm not flying you to New
York I will see you in mmm February in
Indianapolis Indiana because I will be
there for 2 or 3 days for the NFL
Combine and we were going to go to st.
elmo's right
incredible steakhouse James that's where
I'm taking you if that works for you
now he's gonna email and be like I want
to see your I'll hang with you longer if
we can do it Indianapolis screams thank
you so much this is where it ends up and
this is where I need me texting me in 15
minutes when I'm done with my car ride
home saying it exploded after you left
this is the point where I'm gonna sign
off and I just it just means a lot to me
if you can come through for me if if you
are in the state where we can ship in
America and you can like even if you
don't drink wine if you can figure out
how to give 9 bottles away in a year you
know it would just you can to be very
frank for a lot of you that want to just
give me a birthday gift or just to thank
you for everything we've done you guys
have been a fact
weirdly that would be the ultimate you
buy 3 pack on recurring and every time
you get it you give it to 3 people which
gets them into the line and that's how I
can really build this it would mean the
world to me
I highly recommend Club empathy that's a
case of each highly recommend you get
billed to 40 today for Jose then you get
billed in June and October of 2019 if
you're thinking about cash flow
corporate gifts Gary Vee comm slash gift
I really want to be your corporate gift
partner please fill that out but as I
sign off here as we hang up and you stop
watching if you can all go to empathy
wines calm and buy a three pack or a
Club empathy that would mean the world
to me thank you so so much thank you for
all the birthday wishes I see them all
playing through I'm gonna look at social
on the way out right now thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you for
jamming with me I'm gonna jump up on
Shawn between now and Thanksgiving I'll
probably jump I'll probably beat I might
do a Black Friday thing like I need the
stuff thirty [ __ ] thousand cases I've
sold like five hundred so I got a lot of
[ __ ] work to do I don't wanna go to
business I appreciate you it would mean
a lot a lot if you could support right
now thank you love you bye